so this is up and leave your first TV
show or my the or my wrong about this I
think a million and three years ago
before you were born I did a Showtime
remake of driving classics they did a
series in the early 90s it was a little
different back you know in terms of
where you are in your career oh yeah I
just moved here I moved here two months
before that or three months before that
yes but that's insane that you booked
something like that that you know right
well I didn't get it she broke her leg
and so they needed the understudy
runner-up I didn't believe him when they
said you almost got it
I think sure well I really did oh well I
am curious though what was it about this
that said I want to be a part of this
well Mike Kelly he's a wonderful person
and a great writer and he's so
interesting and I love what motivates
him to want to write again when he did
revenge it was The Count of Monte Cristo
and the Bernie Madoff scandal and how
that damaged people and in this case he
wanted to explore the idea of choices
and consequence and how we compromised
ourselves ethically to bolster our power
to push forward an agenda to appease
people out of fear or because we want to
be loved or whatever it might be and it
seems really socially relevant right now
when you look around at what's going on
you think hmm
yeah every day I'm curious when you sit
down with him is he telling you the full
arc or is he saying I have an idea
here's the basic thing I want to hand
you some scripts um
the former he said we're going from here
to here and this is who she is and this
is how it and I thought you made that up
in a month are you kidding me what a
mind very special but then of course it
was we're going from here to here but we
don't know what route were taking to get
there so every week it was a bit of a
surprise to see what happened next it
was a pretty fantastic experience I was
gonna say the character seems delicious
to play yes how was it on a weekly thing
for 10 episodes yeah like this character
she's outrageous and so much fun I mean
tapping into things that I don't usually
need to find necessary in my personal
life now I would never she does I don't
I don't think many people would yeah you
know what I mean
Willie yeah I I'm almost out of time if
you have to ask you I've seen the
footage from Judy and it looks
tremendous wanking what can it what can
you tease about it and playing this
iconic person oh yeah you can imagine
you can imagine it was it was terrifying
and it was wonderful and it's such a
special experience there's everybody
involved to us so in love with her we
were showing up and it was sort of like
this huge celebration of her every day
and everybody brought their vest and you
could tell it was because they felt I
don't know just telling this part of her
story was so important so important and
and I'm in love and I'm gonna stay there
I already got to go I'm just gonna say
congrats on this st. and I can't wait to
see Judy oh thanks so what